[Aplausos]
[Música]
si os digo la palabra japón estoy seguro
de que todos pensaréis en el manga los
videojuegos o las empresas tecnológicas
sin ir más lejos tokio parece salida de
una película de ciencia ficción
[Música]
la metrópoli más grande del planeta con
más de 30 millones de habitantes y tiene
los trenes más rápidos las televisiones
más modernas y hasta robots que parecen
humanos en otras palabras que a simple
vista nadie diría que japón está al
borde del colapso económico verdad sin
embargo este país lleva dos décadas
completamente estancado y eso no es lo
peor
japón es también el país más endeudado
del mundo entero debe más de dos veces
su producto interior bruto
[Música]
y su población está decreciendo a pasos
agigantados casi no hay dinero para
pagar las pensiones y los japoneses
hacen jornadas laborables interminables
y apenas tienen vacaciones os lo hemos
dicho muchas veces aquí en visual
político esos grandes gigantes nipones
como hitachi o panasonic están perdiendo
la carrera frente a empresas mucho más
innovadoras en china o eeuu
[Música]
pero esperado un momento porque las
cosas pueden cambiar si me estoy
refiriendo a los juegos olímpicos de
tokio 2020
[Aplausos]
oportunidad única para que el país
entero se vista de gala y se convierta
en el centro de atención de todo el
planeta para que os hagáis una idea
desde que japón ganó la candidatura en
el año 2013 el turismo se ha disparado
de la noche a la mañana y lo mismo
ocurrido con la inversión privada para
el año 2020 tokio tendrá nada menos que
45 nuevos rascacielos y por ejemplo
panasonic va a colocar paneles solares
de última generación por toda la ciudad
para que los asistentes a los juegos
puedan cargar sus coches eléctricos y
son iba a estrenar sus televisiones en
formato o chocar para retransmitir el
evento si habéis oído bien si todavía no
nos hemos acostumbrado al 4k dentro de
poco vamos a tener el 8 acá que
permitirá que veamos hasta las costuras
de las camisetas de los atletas
pero esperad un momento porque no todo
es tan bonito veréis cuando tokio ganó
la candidatura olímpica tenía
presupuestado gastarse unos 6500
millones de dólares por dar un poco de
contexto ese dinero es más de lo que
costó la t4 de madrid es uno de los
aeropuertos más grandes de europa pero
una vez han empezado con las obras ya
llevan gastado más del doble y todavía
no han terminado no está nada mal si
tenemos en cuenta que el país del sol
naciente ya lleva una deuda acumulada
además del 230 por ciento de su pib así
que hasta qué punto estos juegos
olímpicos van a ser una oportunidad o un
desastre para japón de verdad los juegos
olímpicos son algo bueno para los
anfitriones hoy vamos a responder a
estas preguntas pero antes vamos a ver
un poco de historia
una falacia olímpica hay pocas cosas que
levanten el orgullo nacional como unos
juegos olímpicos por supuesto que a
todos nos gusta presumir de las medallas
de oro que tiene nuestro país pero lo
que realmente sube el ego patriótico es
ser la ambición de unos juegos
[Música]
el fervor que genera un evento como este
que prácticamente parece que todo el
mundo independientemente de su ideología
está de acuerdo en que organizar unos
juegos olímpicos es bueno para un país
sin embargo dentro del mundo de los
economistas las cosas no están tan
claras es más seamos honestos los
argumentos a favor de ser el anfitrión
de unas olimpiadas son cómo decirlo tan
incongruentes que parecen un guión de
perdidos según un informe del banco de
japón los efectos de los juegos
olímpicos de tokio se están notando
incluso antes de que se hayan celebrado
concretamente el año en el que el comité
olímpico internacional nombró a la
capital japonesa como ciudad anfitriona
se dio el pistoletazo de salida para que
todo el mundo reconozca al país entero
con un destino fantástico para las
inversiones uno de sus principales
argumentos es que si una ciudad gana la
nominación olímpica su país podrá entrar
por la puerta grande en todas esas
grandes organizaciones internacionales
en las que todo país querría ser miembro
queréis ejemplos aquí los tenéis
barcelona empezó a organizar sus juegos
en el año 1986 y justo en ese mismo año
españa entró en la unión europea
beijing fue nombrada anfitrión olímpica
en 2001 el mismo año en el que entró a
formar parte de la organización mundial
del comercio
vamos que parecen argumentos
irrefutables verdad
[Música]
de un momento porque esto es un ejemplo
del libro de falacia de correlación en
otras palabras el hecho de que españa
entrará en la unión europea en el mismo
año en el que barcelona fuera elegida
con transición a olímpica no significa
que lo uno fuera causa de lo otro hecho
tanto grecia como portugal se
convirtieron en miembros del mismo club
sin tener que organizar ningún evento
deportivo
pero ya sé lo que estáis pensando que
hay de la exposición internacional
durante los 15 días que duran los juegos
todo el mundo está pendiente de lo que
ocurre en tu país hablamos del mayor
acontecimiento deportivo del mundo
o tal vez no veréis las olimpiadas de
londres de 2012 consiguieron una
audiencia media de 31 millones de
espectadores en un país como eeuu
[Música]
para que lo comparemos eso es algo así
como dos veces lo que consigue un
episodio de juego de tronos es cierto no
está nada mal pero y qué ha ocurrido con
el resto de juegos olímpicos pues por
ejemplo los juegos de invierno de
sochi-2014 ni siquiera llegaron a los 22
millones de espectadores y los de
rio-2016 se quedaron en los 26 millones
[Música]
pueden parecer cifras muy altas pero se
quedan en nada si las comparamos con las
de otros eventos mucho más baratos como
la superbowl que es sin ir más lejos en
2016 superó los 110 millones de
espectadores
[Música]
en otras palabras que aunque las
olimpiadas se ven en todo el mundo
cuando miramos las cifras de audiencia
país por país
los números no son tan impresionantes y
esto se traduce en que la percepción que
los ciudadanos tienen de un país tampoco
cambia demasiado al menos no para bien
en un estudio sobre el impacto de las
olimpiadas de sydney del año 2000 los
investigadores entrevistaron a gente de
distintos países un año antes y un año
después de los juegos encontraron muy
pocos cambios en las percepciones con
una excepción sorprendente los
sudafricanos estaban descontentos con
australia por el modo en el que se
habían resaltado los problemas con los
aborígenes en los medios sudafricanos
sin embargo hay algo que parece
indiscutible los juegos olímpicos
mejoran el turismo de un país para que
os hagáis una idea desde que tokio fue
elegida como anfitriona el turismo en
japonés se ha multiplicado han pasado de
apenas recibir visitantes del extranjero
a tener más de 24 millones de personas
el año pasado
en un país donde apenas había trabajo
para los hoteles ahora ha nacido un
nuevo sector económico un sector que
atrae ingentes cantidades de dinero del
extranjero a quien no le puede gustar
algo así pues esperad un momento porque
incluso estas cifras son bastante
discutibles por supuesto el turismo en
japón ha crecido una auténtica
barbaridad pero sabéis que otros países
han crecido a un ritmo similar en los
últimos años en chile y tailandia y no
hace falta que lo busquéis ya os lo digo
desde aquí ninguno de estos dos países
tiene previsto celebrar unos juegos
olímpicos
[Música]
el caso de tailandia es especialmente
paradigmático reciben casi 6 millones
más de turistas que japón y tienen poco
más de la mitad de la población y el
crecimiento de su sector turístico está
ligado al crecimiento de la clase media
china en otras palabras a medida que los
chinos tienen más dinero pueden
permitirse viajar y adónde se van pues
lógicamente a países asiáticos que están
cerca y tienen distintos atractivos
turísticos que visitar pero ya se lo que
estáis pensando aunque los juegos
olímpicos no ven tantísimos vídeos cómo
aparece el problema hay con que tokio
quiera tener sus propios juegos a quien
no le gusta tener un estadio gigantesco
en su ciudad pues ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver
[Música]
medalla de oro al gasto todos lo sabemos
los juegos olímpicos cuestan dinero de
la noche a la mañana
tokio va a tener que construir un
estadio olímpico capaz de albergar a más
de 80 mil personas y por supuesto
dejarles sin aliento con luces y colores
también van a necesitar lugares
especiales para que se celebren todas
las competiciones deportivas cada una
con sus especificaciones no es lo mismo
una pista de atletismo que una piscina
olímpica o un estadio para competiciones
de piragüismo
en total se van a construir o remodelar
31 edificios ya eso hay que sumarle el
centro de prensa que también es otra
superproducción arquitectónica y por
encima de todo está la villa olímpica
una especie de mini ciudad donde vivirán
los más de 10.000 deportistas que
participarán en los juegos por supuesto
esta villa tampoco es barata en total
todos los juegos olímpicos se
presupuestaron en el equivalente a 6500
millones de dólares estadounidenses
al menos esa es la cifra que dieron las
autoridades al comité olímpico
internacional en el año 2013 pero ya se
sabe una vez empiezan las obras las
cosas no son como se habían planeado
los costes de los juegos olímpicos de
tokio 2020 siguen subiendo para
diciembre de 2017
el ayuntamiento de tokio ya se había
gastado más de 12 mil millones de
dólares y solo un par de meses más tarde
en la última rueda de prensa las
autoridades locales avisaron de que como
mínimo terminarán gastándose más de 20
mil millones de dólares y todavía quedan
dos años para encender el pebetero en
realidad nada de esto es ninguna
sorpresa
[Música]
de que se tiene memoria todos los juegos
olímpicos terminan costando más de lo
que se había presupuestado y no hablamos
de unos pocos millones de dólares
precisamente los juegos de río de
janeiro de 2016 terminaron saliendo un
51 por ciento más caros pero sin duda
alguna el récord lo tienen los de
montreal de 1976 que terminaron costando
un 700 por ciento más de lo que se había
presupuestado
para que os hagáis una idea eso es ocho
veces el dinero que se había previsto y
os preguntaréis todos esos miles de
millones de dólares son mucho o poco
dinero es decir para el presupuesto que
se gasta un ayuntamiento o un país
entero hablamos de cantidades realmente
grandes pues la respuesta es sí para que
os hagáis una idea con 20 mil millones
de dólares japón podría construir por
ejemplo una autopista que cruzara el
país entero de norte a sur
esperad un momento porque esto no es lo
peor queréis construir autopistas o
aeropuertos puede ser un despilfarro
pero siempre se puede reutilizar país
con buenas comunicaciones puede albergar
nuevas empresas nuevos sectores
económicos o simplemente dar mejores
servicios a los ciudadanos pero cómo se
puede reutilizar un estadio olímpico con
capacidad para albergar a 80 mil
personas desde luego si nos vamos a
ejemplos pasados la respuesta os va a
dejar con mal sabor de boca
[Música]
los edificios olímpicos de ríos ya están
en estado de desastre el caso de río de
janeiro es especialmente duro pese a
haber tenido juegos olímpicos todavía
quedan barrios enteros que ni siquiera
tienen una línea de autobuses que les
conecte al centro y por lo visto las
zonas donde estaba la villa olímpica se
están convirtiendo rápidamente en
barrios marginales y lo peor es que este
no es el único ejemplo
el estadio olímpico de atenas está en
ruinas 10 años después de los juegos de
2004 a todo esto tenemos que sumarle el
hecho de que japón tiene la deuda más
grande del mundo entero y que el
gobierno ya tiene problemas incluso para
pagar las pensiones de sus jubilados
hablamos además de un país que lleva más
de dos décadas sin crecer económicamente
así que la pregunta es significarán los
juegos olímpicos de tokio la ruina de
japón o tal vez los japoneses serán la
excepción y serán capaces de sacar algún
beneficio después de tantísimo gasto
podeis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y si queréis saber más sobre
ese modelo económico japonés que tiene
algún que otro problema hace clic en
este vídeo y como siempre no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribirse a visual
polític para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Aplausos]
[Música]